You were on the cover
of Men's Health.
He's getting
a lot of slack
for taking his shirt off
all the time.
I don't get it.
I don't understand that.
Justin, let me
tell you something, man.
Okay, if you can take
your shirt off, you do it.
You do it as much
as you Goddamn can.
Seriously.
Look at Shaq--Shaq--
Shaq hasn't taken his shirt off
since high school, okay?
That's a true story.
That's a true story right there.
Jeff Ross hasn't taken
his shirt off since preschool.
True story.
Martha Stewart had her shirt off
in my dressing room.
Stop, stop, stop.
Don't get the wrong idea.
She just wanted me
to titty fuck her!
Yeah!
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry. Stop.
I'm just trying
to loosen y'all up.
I'm sorry.
Martha, I'm sorry.
Is that gonna affect me getting
free sheets after this, Martha?
Please.
I messed up my chance
of getting free sheets,
Goddamn it, Kevin.